[Music]
the thing about black holes is they're
omnivores they'll eat anything anything
that gets close to them they'll gobble
up one way black holes can grow so large
is by eating other black holes so in a
sense they may be cannibals a black hole
merger is the most violent the most
energetic thing that happens in the
universe
period
picture the scene 1.3 billion years ago
two black holes circle each other and a
dance of death the larger black hole
pulls the smaller one in words until
they're locked together in a spiral
very very slowly that orbit is decaying
they're getting closer and closer and
closer and then they will merge into one
giant black hole truly one of the most
dramatic events in the universe finally
they collide in one of the largest bangs
since the Big Bang I would have loved to
been able to safely view the collision
of these two black holes up close
imagine these two black holes as they
spiraling toward each other going faster
and faster and faster and faster and
then suddenly where there appears to be
nothing or just distortions in space in
front of you suddenly there was this
enormous burst of energy and everything
just rings around our Sun is burning
about a hundred billion hydrogen bombs
every second and over its ten billion
year lifetime it will convert less than
maybe 1% of the mass of the Sun to
energy in two-tenths of a second three
times the mass of the Sun in matter got
converted to energy in that collision
it was 36 septillion yata watts what
does that mean a lot of freaking energy
that's more energy in that 2/10 of a
second than is emitted by all the stars
in the visible universe in the same time
you